so this talk is signal our above and
beyond chat so thank you all for coming
I'm really excited about signal art and
hopefully you'll find out why very soon
my name is David pine a Microsoft and VP
and Google developer expert so there's
about 700 plus Google developer experts
around the globe and over 3,000 MVPs but
I've only met two others that hold both
at the same time so it's a super super
gratifying feeling to have that
recognition from two awesome companies
so I'm excited about that you can follow
me on twitter at david pine 7 and then
also I maintain a blog at David Pine net
where I blog about all the things so
check that out one thing I like to
preface my talks with is that I love the
developer community so who's just show
of hands who does Twitter who's seen the
developer community hashtag that's a
hashtag you should watch for I'm a big
proponent of it my story is that back in
2016 I first started speaking and I was
terrified that there's always like an
adrenaline rush and getting up in front
of a crowd and putting yourself out
there and potentially feeling like
you're gonna be judged right there's
this innate sense of imposter syndrome
that hits you and you feel like a lesser
individual but afterwards right after
you've done it enough it's really
awesome it's really great and it's
something that I think every sitting on
one of you here today in attendance
could absolutely do so I hope that you
do it because for me the developer
community has been something I could
lean on I've been taking from it for so
long that I decided to give back so with
that let's jump into signal our signal
our so it's open source are there any
open source developers in the room today
and by that I mean like active on
potentially you know github looking at
the various source code that's available
out there no don't show hands couple of
people okay so open sources there's a
community there also right so the
developer community isn't just
presenters or people who blog or answer
questions on Stack Overflow
there's a community within open-source
so open source is amazing for lots of
reasons you can do lots of things with
it right you can see how things are made
you can see how others interact with
their design patterns you can learn from
them be humbled by them and then also
provide back you can do pull requests
you can fork and branch and do all these
things and it's really amazing and I
think it's awesome that Microsoft
pivoted and made so many things
open-source so signal art is offering up
real-time web functionality and by that
I mean it's enabling server and client
interaction so it's a duplex
communication so what that actually does
is the server can send unsolicited
messages to the client that's pretty
cool right but it's also duplex so that
the client can do the same to the server
so the benefits when we start thinking
about the benefits of signal are I have
three young sons and whenever we do
family trips we travel it's it's
interesting because they're always like
are we there yet right show of hands if
you have kids you've heard that are you
there yet so right imagine the typical
web server request response pipeline
it's very similar to kids asking are we
there yet on a family vacation trip so
the kids will say are we there yet no
are we there yet
no are we there yet no and then
eventually you're there and you're like
this is great right we're there they you
know get the information that we're
having the vacation it's finally you
know all the anticipation is built up
the same is true with requests and
responses within webs right so rather
than having a client browser say do you
have information form yet do you have
information form yet and then the server
saying nope nope nope okay now I have
information here it is this is this is
one of the benefits of signal are right
so it alleviates that concern so use
cases are real-time all the things so
think about you know obviously in the
name of this
we're talking about a chat application
but we're gonna go far beyond just chat
but chat is a great example because who
uses slack everyone who uses skype uses
teams who uses something else okay so
that's a real-time those are you know if
it's not if you're not using it the the
desktop client or mobile app typically
that's a real-time web functionality
that's enabled by a technology similar
to signal are right where things happen
in real time so there's other use cases
for it as well beyond that imagine like
collaborating on a whiteboard or stock
ticker things of that nature and it's
everywhere you want to be because the
web is everywhere so signal are has been
around for a very long time as it
pertains to asp net framework what we're
talking about today is signal our core
right so asp net core came around and
then it's it's like a rewrite of that an
initial vision of signal are so there's
various platforms that this can be
consumed on so with asp net core that's
your that's where you're gonna host that
you're gonna be the other server and
then you'll have different clients that
can connect to that so some of the
platforms that exist today are the
javascript client I put in parenthesis
ie 11 because that's where it's at for
ie everything else you know browser wise
it'll just work there's a dotnet client
so I think about iOS and Android right
Samer and stuff like that there's a Java
client right so that's pretty cool
there's also a C++ client that's in the
works they're targeting that for the 3.0
release of dotnet core and then there's
a third party implementation for Swift
so there's seemingly endless ways to
consume this so let's take a look at
this so with asp net core there was a
bunch of
naming conventions that were introduced
you know kind of following what existed
before with the this notion of a startup
right think Owen cantana
so we have a start-up and then we have
configure services within configure
services you have an AI service
collection and this is how we wire up
dependency injection and dependency
injection is a first-class citizen of
asp net core so this is very typical so
we'll walk up to the services and we'll
say dot add signal R and this will add
all the signal our services that are
required for us to start consuming it
also we have configure and this is where
you explicitly say how you want to use
those services right so we'll say app
dot you signal R and then we have a
routes object and we're gonna map our
hub so when we say map hub this is a
strongly typed c-sharp subclass of hub
and hub is a type that's provided by
signal R so we have a chat hub here and
we're mapping it to the chat endpoint
okay pretty straightforward so we're a
few lines of code into it and we can you
know basically already wire up for
dependency injection the consumption of
an endpoint that maps to our strongly
typed chat hub that will allow us to do
some very interesting things so you have
to think to yourself right if we're
hosting an app imagine that we're
hosting like a website and then we also
want to have signal are in there you
might start thinking well how do we
handle scalability right if we have tens
of thousands of users what can we do to
off put the concern for scalability so
we start thinking about the cloud and
asier has recently added a first-class
citizen of signal R as a service in the
cloud so to add signal are the Azure
service you just say dot add as your
signal are right and then that will
handle all of the scalability for you
and you
configure that as you would any other
Azure service so that additional line of
code is all that's going to be needed so
let's talk about transports transports
or the mechanism in which the client and
the server communicates so it's the
technology underneath so typically
you're gonna prefer WebSockets as its
most performance the best transport is
automatically chosen based on the server
and clients capabilities right so it'll
just fall back one thing that's
different from asp net cores version of
signal are versus what was in framework
years ago they they had originally
fallen back to forever frame this is no
longer available so if the client
doesn't support WebSockets but the
server does but the client does support
server sent events and the server does
that'll be the transport that's chosen
for that communication so I have a demo
this is demo one of three a fairly
ambitious talk before lunch I might say
so we're gonna start talking about the
chat app and fair warning spoiler alert
many of you have potentially seen what
Microsoft has presented for the the you
know previous several major events where
they talk about here's signal arc or
here's the chat application with view
Jas so I took it a bit further and just
kind of explored what was possible so
within our startup before I continue can
everyone in the back see is the the
contrast good the font size everything's
okay good
so we have a startup class we configure
services we add our authentication we
add some chat services let's go take a
look at these services specifically
because those are kind of nice to
highlight
in our chat application I decided to add
a hosted service and a hosted service
was also a new concept introduced in asp
net core where it lets you in proc run a
back ground service right so we can have
something running outside of the context
of the request response pipeline that's
just always running okay and in this
case I added a chat bot service because
it's fairly difficult to demonstrate in
front of a live audience a chat
application if you're not having anyone
on the other end right so I've got a
chat bot service that I can chat to so
then we say add signal R and then add as
your signal R and then as mentioned
before we'll use signal R and in this
case I'm still using the Azure signal
are here this wasn't with donna 3.0 this
is not going to be needed so I'm using
some older bits I decided not to risk
updating my preview stuff to the latest
so we have very simple razor pages
application so this isn't NBC this is
razor pages so it's still using the
razor View engine so we get our very
familiar looking HTML CSH tml files and
we can do data binding and stuff like
that so in this particular case we have
a chat element and we have a transition
group and we're doing some little
animations here with a list and we have
some pretty CSS so we'll have some list
items right and we're using view J s as
I mentioned before so we have some
binding syntax we can iterate over our
messages that are coming in and we'll
take a look at the view J s app in just
a second and then we have the capability
to post messages from here in this
markup as I mentioned it's pretty
straightforward so over here we have our
JavaScript and this is where our view J
s app lives
so the server again hosted on asp net
core has signal are running and we have
a chat hub and we'll look at that in a
second I want to show you the client
that's first so we are consuming a
signal our hub connection builder and
we're pointing to that same chat hub
right we're going to build that out
that's our connection we can then use
that connection to connect to the server
and we have a new view application
targeting that element this is the ID of
that element we have some data this is
basically just state within the context
of our application messages little map
of those a current user whether or not
the user is typing some emojis and we
even have notifications for when like a
user logs on we have a watch this is
unique to view j/s this allows us to
basically watch when the message change
changes so when the user is typing a
message in their chat window we can
debounce that such that we won't send
off a communication until after 750
milliseconds so it's a way to kind of
buffer and wait for them to stop typing
and we'll use that actually to
communicate to other users that a user
is typing so within slack who's seeing
that little kind of type-ahead you know
like where people are typing and who's
watched at with angst and said they're
typing they're typing they haven't you
know they stopped right and then all of
a sudden you're like when are they gonna
hit Enter are they editing this like
what's going on right so I do that a lot
probably worry too much and then we have
some other things that we compute right
we'll have some flashing text will get
which users are typing we have some
messages or methods here so we can post
a message we can set whether or not the
users typing just a bunch of little
things that allow us to interact with
our HTML right so we can edit so we can
receive the message we can send them off
let me see here real quick so we can
down here we have the connection object
so we walk up to the connection and we
say dot on and we give it a method name
so on this connection once it's
established we'll handle this event the
message received event as follows right
we get the JSON payload and then we'll
walk up to our app and context which is
our view j/s application on the client
and we know that it has messages so we
can set the messages from the JSON
payload right then the message has an ID
and then the message itself will nudge
the app to tell it to hey repaint the
screen if it's an edit or if it's from a
chatbot we'll do certain things right
one thing I'm giving away here is that
if it's from the chat bot and we're
saying it's a joke our chat bot is
actually going to speak to us right so
it's not just gonna be a message that
shows up and how we're doing that is
with some native JavaScript so browsers
today so support speech synthesis so we
can give it a message we can get some
voices I'm saying any Google US English
voice here and then we'll tell it to
speak so let's look at the chat hub
itself real quick
inside the chat hub again this is the
strongly typed class that we're mapping
to that chat endpoint and as I mentioned
we're a subclass of hub hub is coming
from a SP net signal R and we have some
dependency injection here we have a
command signal this is how I'm figuring
out whether or not a message is actually
a command right so I can command my chat
bot explicitly I can tell it jokes and
I'll start randomly saying jokes right
so we're overriding unconnected and
unconnected is a function that occurs
within hubs so we can override that and
then we have this collection of clients
right in our hub these clients are all
the connected clients to the hub at that
particular time of connection
I can say caller and caller is
explicitly it's kind of used as an echo
so a caller is the caller of the
connection at that point in time so when
we're connecting we can pump a message
back out to the caller so we can say you
know hi username this is the chat
application powered by signal are we
treat it as a greeting and we have the
user as just waving hand the other thing
that we'll do is we'll broadcast out to
others so others is everyone every
connected client other than the
individual that initiated that
connection method invocation and that's
when we're gonna say user logged on
so other clients that are on the chat
application will get a little toaster
that says hey so-and-so just logged on
right so you could potentially start
messaging them if you wanted to the same
is true with disconnections so we'll
walk up to others and say that hey this
user just logged off and then this is
how we go about posting a message so
we're given a message and if it's not a
command signal we'll return otherwise
we're going to broadcast that message
out to all and we'll just pass along the
message with some other information and
if the user is typing we have the
username in context already so we'll
just broadcast that out to everyone else
to let them know that that user is
typing and that's pretty much that so
let's run this
so as we see here we got our initial
greeting right so signal are we already
know is wired up the request of the
server happened the server responded
with our server-side rendered CS HTML so
razor pages kicked in
it did its thing we have our HTML on the
client here and then the client did some
other stuff where it went and asked for
some JavaScript and then our view j/s
application spun up it established that
connection right to that endpoint on the
server for the chat hub and then it said
okay now we're connected so on the
server that unconnected event occurred
and then we broadcast out a message to
whoever is online so they'll get a
message that I just logged on and then
we also kicked back a message right via
clients not caller this is like an echo
so now I can see hi david pine 7:00 this
is the chat application powered by
single arm so that's pretty cool right
so now it's just just a chat app right
we can go up here we can edit this blah
blah blah blah right let me say it's
edited other people can come in here I'm
alone though right now so that's kind of
depressing and sad don't feel bad for me
as I mentioned before I added that
hosted service so there's actually a
background service and as I showed with
the post message there's a command
signal waiting so I as a consumer of
this who have some underlying knowledge
of the system I can walk up to this and
post a message called jokes and before I
hit enter I'm gonna explain to you what
it's gonna do so jokes is gonna walk up
to that post message it's gonna be
recognized as a command signal right and
our hub and then it's gonna start off
the host of service in the background
it's gonna say hey I know you're sitting
back there start start telling me some
jokes those jokes are gonna come in
we're gonna get type-ahead saying that
the joke bot is typing to us and as
those messages come in they're gonna be
spoken to us it sound good
their dad jokes by the way I adopted my
dog from a blacksmith as soon as we got
home he made a bold for the door
yeah but don't write and it's random so
every five to thirty seconds the dad
joke BOTS will start giving us new jokes
and what that simply is doing is it's
using the HTTP client to walk up to I
Can Has dad joke it's a free API service
that exists do you want a brief
explanation of what an acorn is in a
nutshell it's an elk tree they don't get
any better but there's a free service
for that so we just basically tethered
together a string of all these
interesting technologies seamlessly
right we have a full chat application we
can host why was the picture sent to
prison
it was framed I'll stop again the jokes
don't get much better but yeah so we
basically put together this application
pretty seamlessly it supports it sits up
an azure I'll give you a link for that
but it's pretty powerful how we can
utilize these technologies and
collectively this is the entire app
probably under 500 lines of code and
we're doing all these things right is
that pretty cool so just recap we saw
razor pages they're utilizing view j/s
that was the JSON protocol we're gonna
get more into protocols in a bit and
this was actually using the azure signal
are so we could scale seemingly
endlessly right we could handle a lot
more scenarios and feel free to take a
picture of this bitly this is the link
to the azure hosted version of this
application and since you know the
command you can go show this off to your
friends and say check out these amazing
jokes that are hysterical right so we
looked at hubs yeah I'll show the bitly
again at the end with all the resources
and I'll share this on my Twitter also
so when we start thinking about hubs
hubs are like the central piece they are
the proxy betwixt the server and the
clients this is how the server and the
client can communicate right and again
it's a duplex communication
so the server can send stuff to the
client once that connection is
established and vice versa so it's
really really powerful so all the things
that you're thinking of right now those
are things that you can do with this so
in the previous example one thing you
might have noticed is that we had a chat
hub and we had some magic strings on the
server right we said
message received like a string literal
and some people are against magic
strings some people are ok with them one
thing that you can't do is you can't
alleviate those on the clients but from
the server they do offer up strongly
typed hubs and those can be hubs of T
where you give it an interface and then
that basically changes what's available
on that clients object such that you can
have the interfaces implementations to
handle those communications so I wanted
to talk a bit about some of the
different offerings and how we can
specify right how granular can we get
with the communications that we're
pumping through signal are right we have
this clients which is again a collection
of all the clients connected at that
point in time so if we wanted to
broadcast right imagine a broadcast
scenario much like what we were seeing
when we type a message and a chat right
we'll send that to all right so that's
broadcasting to all the connected
clients so this is me Dave on the sender
so when I say here's a message this
server the chat hub will get that and it
will regurgitate it to everyone right
see how the arrow goes between me and
the server so I'm sending it to the chat
hub the chat hub is then saying BAM here
it is to everyone okay so the echo
that's how we basically got that
unconnected event we called back to the
caller right so that's how we got that
little greeting message so I'm
connecting to the server I'm connecting
to that chat hub so we can say at that
point in time we're gonna refer to this
as like an echo right so we're walking
up to the caller whoever and
Shadid that request will we'll be able
to target that so that's that's me right
so I connect to it the chat hub says
here's something right we can send it to
others this is how we can broadcast when
people connect write or sign on you
don't want to know that you signed on
because you've just signed on right so
we'll send it to everyone else to let
them know that you did sign on so that's
others so notice how the arrow doesn't
come back to me so Dave sends it to the
chat hub the chat hub then propagates it
to all the other people we can send it
to a group right so imagine not not
unlike what slack offers right where
they have the notion of channels or
HipChat we'll have like rooms this
HipChat Silla thing so right do you have
rooms those are basically just groups
those are little little ways that we can
communicate and with that so you'll give
it a group name and you can send a
targeted message of any type to a group
so in a chat chat application imagine
that I want to send something off to my
friends Maggie and Rachel who are on the
UX team so they're part of you act so I
could send a message to you X and I
don't even have to be a member of that
group we can do direct messages this is
probably one of my favorite to talk
about because who hasn't done direct
messages and if you say you haven't
you're lying to yourself because
everyone talks crap about other people
so right so you can target an individual
user this way right if you have their
user ID you can say you're gonna send
them a direct message and in this case
I'm messaging Maria so I send a message
the chat hub gets it and it then
propagates it directly to Maria so I
mentioned before protocols and how the
chat app I wrote was using Jason so
Jason is obviously text-based it's human
readable it's nice to have if you're you
know debugging you want to ensure like a
payload right you can open up the
network tab and you can see the
those messages coming over the wire and
since they're in Jason you can inspect
them and you can see what they look like
and you can handle them appropriately
but since its text-based and it's human
readable it's potentially bloated so
there's some optimizations that you can
consider with the various protocols that
are available in this particular case
message pack so message pack is binary
and it's roughly roughly 60% the size of
adjacent payload so 40% savings is
pretty nice right so the signal our
protocol is it's basically a protocol
like I mentioned before for a two-way
RPC write remote procedure calls over
any message based transport so these are
the two current implementations of those
protocols since it's open source and
since they do have an official spec you
can go out there and implement your own
write you can have like an emoji based
one if you wanted to for whatever reason
so we have another demo and in this demo
we're going to we're going to look at a
different type of application
some people had mentioned earlier that
one of their favorite talks at NDC
Minnesota 2019 was webassembly and
Blaser so this is a blazer application
and what I decided to do was to switch
it up a bit so some of the advantages of
what blazer was offering is this notion
of solving the problem that exists with
spa applications today where they're in
JavaScript I mean that's not the problem
obviously the problem is you know
marrying up api's right so whatever
technology your web api is built-in it
has a model that is going to rescind
back it's gonna it has a response right
that payload has a defined structure and
if you write asp net core web api you
can imagine having
c-sharp class that represents that and
if you have for example like an angular
application or some other you know
JavaScript thing how do you marry up
those types right how do you marry up
what the the web api is sending back and
what the JSON is being parsed as write
that how do you how do you map that up
that's kind of hard to manage right
because things can change so with blazer
what they're doing is they have this
notion of dotnet running in the client
browser so since its dot now you have a
c-sharp class or c-sharp
capabilities right so you can share your
models so the models that are coming
from the web api can be the same models
that are receiving it on the client
right like what that's amazing if you're
into c-sharp of course so let's take a
look at this we have the server-side
bits and in here on the server we're
adding signal are we're adding message
prac a message pack protocol this is
where I'm explicitly stating that my
protocol is not the default which is
Jason it's going to be message pack so
this is the binary stuff that I
mentioned before and then we have a
Twitter service so we're registering
Twitter so I'm kind of giving you a hint
about this application
great it's Blazer great it's got signal
arm but what are we going to do with it
so what I've decided to do was consume a
Twitter SDK and we're going to do some
streaming with it so in our application
when the server starts up it's going to
start listening for a set of handles and
hash tags and it's going to be streaming
so as those hash tags or handles occur
on Twitter live right think again
real-time web as they occur an event
will fire and that event will occur on
the server and then we will propagate
that with signal are up to the client
which is a dotnet application which is
going to be listening for those events
as well right
via signal our and then we'll paint them
on the screen right so it's kind of like
a poor person's Twitter so to speak so
let's take a look at a little bit more
of this so we are using signal are I'm
specifying that I want WebSockets or
long pulling as a fallback so I skipped
over server-sent events just to
demonstrate that capability then we have
a stream hub we'll look at the stream
hub I'll just look at it right now so
the stream hub is basically just
utilizing the decorator pattern here and
we're consuming that twitter service and
we're expressing some capabilities right
so we're removing tracks and adding
tracks tracks are synonymous with
handles and hashtags and Twitter for
this Twitter SDK and then we're saying
that we want to start the tweets stream
and then we can pause it and stop it so
let's look at what the the tweet stream
stuff is actually doing so we wire up to
a bunch of events with our filtered
stream from the Twitter SDK and then
once we get one of those events to fire
we'll we'll take this action and we can
basically create an embedded tweet and
then send that along to the hub context
so this is not an actual hub no this is
the context of a hub so it's slightly
different
so our service doesn't have direct
contact to the hub we have the context
so it's a contextual hub so we can still
do similar things with it so let's look
at our client-side bits real quick over
here we have some markup this is again
CS HTML it's pretty simple 70 lines of
markup and with the help of bootstrap
and some layout we have basically all of
those tracks the after mention tracks
laid out so we'll have the handles in
the hash tag
and then we have start and stop buttons
and then as tweets come in right we have
tweets here if there's any tweets we'll
basically for each over those tweets
will render them as a mark up string and
plot them in our list okay so pretty
straightforward the code-behind right
the Blazer component for that has just a
hard-coded read only list right now of
those tracks so this is your clue as a
consumer of this talk if you're on
Twitter now might be a good time to pull
out your phone and start typing in some
of these hashtags potentially getting
ready to take a picture because it's
going to show up on the screen so we're
injecting the stream service and this is
our client-side service this is how we
were connecting to the right we have the
hub connection builder with that URL and
we're also using message pack right and
so from here we're saying we're going to
start that connection and much like we
saw with JavaScript it's very similar in
terms of like the naming convention so
we could say connection dot on tweet
received and this is our function which
is just basically a tweet result
returning a task this is our handler and
this is how we're gonna take those
tweets and kind of build them up inside
our components list and then as that
happens we'll paint them on the screen
so let's run this I'm gonna pull up my
phone and prepare a tweet
six six six five five six five - okay
that's gonna load loving the developer
community here at NDC Minnesota so you
can see the application right we were
listening for hashtag developer
community hashtags signal our hashtag
MDC MN asp.net my handle all these
things right oh look at that someone's
already chiming in cool I'm gonna take a
picture myself here you guys give me
some like metal horns like something
like yeah you guys are excited to be
here sweet okay I'm gonna tweet that BAM
that should come through momentarily now
as that tweets coming through again
what's happening is the server is
listening using the Twitter SDK that's
you guys right it's using the Twitter
SDK it's listening for those events
those handles and hashtags as those
events occur they they come through that
hub context where I can propagate then
to the blazer side and say hey this
tweet occurred here it is right and it's
awesome oh and this one's not loading
well so one of the things when I shared
that I was building this out I thought
it was a pretty compelling demo and
someone said that's a great idea
but actually it's not a great idea
because you're an idiot and I was like
wait a second why right oh my feelings
were hurt and I was upset by that so as
it turns out someone had already done
something similar to this where they
tried encouraging the audience to do
live tweets and up there you know morale
or whatever but they're like someone
rained on my parade
someone put a tweet that came through
that said something that was you know
potentially sensitive that might have
been offensive to others and it just
wrecked the vibe right everyone was
super distraught by that so just be
aware of it and I said well I can do
something about that
so what I did was in my application as
tweets come in
and before I broadcast them off the the
SDK itself the tweets they have a is
potentially sensitive bit right that's
coming from Twitter so I'll trust
Twitter that I'm sure if based on how
your account settings are you might have
seen that so I said great all queue on
that and if it is potentially sensitive
I'll take it a step further what I did
was I integrated the sentiment analysis
from ML dotnet so if you haven't seen
that that's the machine learning net SDK
that you can then download and use in
your applications so on the server if I
receive a tweet that's potentially
sensitive I'll run it against this
machine learning algorithm for its
sentiment and if the sentiment is
predicted to be less than ideal I'll
just completely ignore that tweet
I've been really tempted to put a
breakpoint here during these demos to
say bring it on let's see what you guys
can do and see if I can actually you
know kick it out but it's just a theory
so don't actually try that because
something might sneak through but it's
pretty cool right that we can do that
well this is definitely not my talk but
apparently Amy's killing it the right
we're queueing on those things that's
awesome
all right close that
cool so just a recap that was a s peanut
core plus blazer that was using the
message pack protocol so again that's
binary it might make things a little bit
quicker less payload over the wire it
was utilizing the Twitter streaming SDK
and that's the bit leaf for it and
that's the link to the source code
itself so if you have a visual studio
and you want to go play with it you can
literally go download this and start
running it and seeing how all the things
were kind of put together so it's worth
mentioning performance right we had just
talked about message pack and some of
the things you might want to consider
when you start analyzing how you would
use signal are right the benefits
so with asp net core who's been
following some of the tech and power
benchmarks so it's pretty impressive to
see that as of just recently they had
passed seven million requests per second
I'm gonna let that sink in for a second
because that is like holy cow that's
insane right that's crazy to think about
that I think they're like what like the
top in the top three or something like
that for web servers and processing
speed so it's really really impressive
what they're doing
but once I share this deck you'll be
able to look at not only the asp net
core benchmarks but also the signal our
benchmarks and those benchmarks this is
a link here I don't want to dive into it
too much but basically it takes you out
to a power bi and it's aggregated all of
the azure services signal ours
performance so you can actually see the
performance and you can start comparing
like what's the message pack protocol
doing versus Jason or what about
WebSockets versus server sent events and
how does that look and right you have
all the data there to start making these
kind of performance based decisions
about how you want to approach
developing a solution it's really nice
to mention that they actually have a
spec as I said at the beginning of the
talk asp net framework signal AR has
been around for like nearly a decade
and it was amazing now was asp net Coors
vision of it the rewrite they actually
took a step back and said let's do this
a little bit more iteratively and they
introduced a formal spec right so the
signal our protocol it's the protocol
for the RPC over any message based
transport so you can with the
specifications you can look at the hubs
you can look at the protocols and you
can follow the spec and again you can
implement your own version of these
things but it's nice to see how under
the covers that they have like an actual
spec right we have a final demo let's
close this so over here we have this
application is another another look at
kind of one-upping what Microsoft has
done in terms of demos and stuff like
that so they they had written you may
have seen it but there's Stream streamer
stream are it's basically like an ASCII
art taking the video camera turning it
into ASCII art and then you can you know
view and watch and it's streaming and I
rewrote that but rather than relying on
some of the third-party libraries I
wrote it by hand because why not it's
JavaScript what how bad could it be and
I did it in angular so we we were
leveraging typescript so let's take a
look at this real quick again very very
common nomenclature for our startup we
have spa static files right because we
are an angular application but then we
get to the familiar bits of adding
signal R and the message pack protocol
and then down here we're going to
configure how we're going to use that
and then we have a stream hub right on
this stream endpoint and then here's our
stream hub this has a stream service and
our service this is where things get a
little bit more interesting so rather
than just straight up messages signal
ours offering like true streaming
capabilities they added some new
primitive types so they have channel
readers and channel writers and those
are kind of lower level implementations
that allow you to read and write with
like stream semantics so let's look at
our service our stream service has a
concurrent dictionary of a string and a
stream reference we can list those
streams out and then we have a way to
execute a stream so this is basically
starting a stream so imagine our client
app we're gonna take a look at the
client side bits in just a second but
we're going to have the capabilities of
our server starting a stream given a
channel reader so it's gonna be able to
read from that right so the stream will
wait to read a sink and it's gonna try
to read them out and then it's gonna for
each over each of those references and
then right back to all of the writers so
this is basically all the things that
are listening on that and then enter
angular right so we have some markup we
have a home component this is only 49
lines of code here but we have a way to
share a stream given a stream name then
we have the capability of streams kind
of being broadcast into us so that
signal our will communicate here's these
streams that others are broadcasting so
you're a client you open up the URL in
your browser and you want to share your
stream it'll list on other you know
clients browsers so they can click on it
and say they want to watch your stream
so that's the available list here and
then the component itself I will admit
that it gets very complex seeing again I
don't know why I decided to write this
all by hand but I did so basically we
have child elements within the context
of our view we're getting element
reference these are elements to the Dom
so we have the video elements we have
canvas we have ASCII and the ASCII is a
pre tag so it's you know mono space
looks like code
and then we have those actual elements
and we have a canvas rendering 2d
context then we have a subject this is
not to be mistaken with rxjs is subject
this is signal our subject and this is
what we'll map over to a channel reader
so very much like we've seen before the
client will new up a hub connection
builder we're gonna say we want the
message pack protocol against the stream
URL and then we have a way we can
broadcast and handle when streams are
created and when they're removed and we
have some error handling here for when
it closes we can reconnect we have our
various characters one thing you'll
notice about the characters here these
ASCII characters are basically weighted
by the the amount of space that they
fill up so on the far left this is gonna
occupy more space whereas a dot will not
occupy that much space and that's how
we're gonna map over individual data
from each frame so let's go show you
that real quick so when we start the web
camera we're gonna basically this is all
native JavaScript so we're asking for
the media services that are available
and then we're going to basically start
wiring up how we're going to connect to
the camera and then we're going to let's
we're gonna draw frames so what's really
happening here is we have a canvas
element we have our video element we're
taking the source from that video stream
right from our local webcam we're
plotting it on that canvas and then
every 150 milliseconds we're taking a
capture like a one single frame of that
canvas at a point in time and then we're
asking for its naita native data right
so there's each individual pixel we can
iterate over each individual pixel and
we'll run it over an algorithm that says
hey how does this like what's the color
adapt how does this look and then we'll
plot it and give it a specific ASCII
character right and then that's what
we're gonna assign to our pre tag
so we have ASCII art from a video stream
so I'm gonna start this real quick and
it's pretty cool to look at it's not
necessarily ideal but it's a way to do
like pseudo streaming of ASCII art
because why not
so 4 4 3 8 5
I wait for this to load
and I'm gonna load up two different
browsers the reason I'm doing two
browsers is to demonstrate that one will
be able to start creating a stream right
so it's ASCII art and it's gonna pump
that string through signal R and then
we're gonna say that o streams showed up
on the other side and they can start
consuming them right so let's take a
look at that
here's NDC actually let's do this way do
you see over here where I start
streaming wait for it we're over here on
you guys well that's the wrong camera
huh okay so over here we got that stream
we're gonna watch it and just like that
we're broadcasting right so we're able
in one browser to consume and want to
publish right so it's sudo streaming
with ASCII art because ASCII art is
amazing there's no better way to to view
a video stream right there pretty cool
all right see how much time we have
perfect okay so a recap that was asp net
core with angular right and then we did
message pack again but that's it was
basically a video ASCII art studio
streaming and kind of demonstrating how
you can use channel readers and writers
and what that looks like and again it's
just all the different things that you
can do or think of you can probably do a
signal R so it's just trying to find a
specific use case for it this is the
resources that I mentioned before the
first bitly there is the live app up in
Azure the second and third bit Li is the
github repository for the source code if
you follow me on twitter I'll be sure to
tweet out all the other locations for
the stuff that we cover today I'll let
people take a pictures here
awesome with that thank you so so much
for having me it's been an honor to come
to NDC and I'm humbled by all the people
here and thanks again I'll be around if
you have questions Thanks
[Applause]
and be sure to vote sessions you can put
red yellow or green hopefully agree